[Musik]
zusammen zdf heute live ihr euer leben
zu aktuellen ereignissen und diskussion
herzlich willkommen
wir diskutieren gerade sehr hart und
schaaf seit ein paar tagen über die
frage ob menschen die schon geimpft
wurden mehr dürfen sollen wieder können
ich glaube dass berger mathematisch
nicht ganz korrekt aber ich glaube ich
wisst ihr wisst was ich meine
also sollen die quasi dinge wieder
dürfen die menschen ohne impfung noch
nicht dürfen zum beispiel so was hier
wieder aufs konzert gehen nur mit
impfungen diskutieren wir seit ein paar
tagen darüber die frage treibt jetzt
auch die politik um
heute hat sich der deutsche ethikrat
dazu geäußert wir sprechen gleich mit
der vorsitzenden professor alena buchs
über diese frage die da mal wieder eine
sehr differenzierte sicht hat fragen und
kommentare interessieren uns wie immer
auch also bitte hier einmal in die dafür
vorgesehenen kommentarspalten schreiben
oder eine gute alte e-mail an zdf heute
- live at zdf.de die kommt dann bei mir
an ich guck was ich mitnehmen kann
aber zuerst möchten die mit jemandem
reden der von diesen ganzen
einschränkungen ziemlich betroffen ist
beruflich privat natürlich auch aber
besonders beruflich denn er kann mit
seiner band sei ja gut einem jahr nicht
mehr auftreten und wir sprechen jetzt
mit smudo von den fantastischen boland
stimmen ab mal ganz persönlich gefragt
ist gerade die stimmung bei dir und bei
euch ich glaube die stimmung ist ganz
ich nun bei mir und bei unserem
allgemeinen nicht so gut also keiner hat
mehr alles in dem lockdown blues das ist
natürlich keine schöne stimmung hinzu
kommt dass wir natürlich wir haben
betten letztes jahr 30 jahre die
fantastischen vier gemacht die tour das
funktioniert nicht wir haben die vertagt
auf dieses jahr und sollte es dann nicht
geben werden wir sie weiter nach vorne
schieben bis es dann wieder geht ja aber
was immer machen
es ist unsere erste pandemie unsere
allererste pandemie wir sind alle der
wird für einen virus und dementsprechend
müssen uns eben auch verhalten dass wir
den virus loswerden ich stell mir das
ein bisschen so vor wie einen hund der
mit flöhen befallen ist da muss quasi
auch jedes körperteil mitmachen sonst
kriegt man den flow nicht los so für
alle die jetzt aus irgendeinem grund
nicht genau wissen wer du bist und was
du gemacht das haben wir ganz kurzen
einspieler gemacht und sich vorzustellen
bitteschön einiger scholz hat das
zusammengestellt
smudo das ist ein teil der fanta 4
sie machten den rap in deutschland
populär doch wie viele andere künstler
trifft auch sie die korona pandemie mit
voller wucht
anstatt auf der bühne zu schwitzen heißt
es zu hause bleiben ihre für 2020
geplante jubiläumstour 30 jahre live
haben sie um ein jahr verschoben
für die fans gab es immerhin ein
trostpflaster den song irgendwann die
message dahinter lasst uns die zeit
zusammen durch die irgendwann schauen
wir auf sie zurück ja also eine
durchhalteparole von den fanta 4 jetzt
gab es gestern eine große diskussion
ausgelöst vom chef des ticket verkäufers
und konzerte an scheiß eventim
er sagte wenn den impfstoff da ist dann
sollte es vielleicht doch möglich sein
dass konzerte nur für geimpfte stadt
denn jetzt habe ich gerade schon ein
abschätziges lachen gehört das heißt
meinung dazu ja ausgerechnet klaus
offenberg kommt sagt so was ja klar der
live branche geht es nicht gut aber das
halte ich natürlich eher von der
botschaft an die aktionäre auch dran zu
bleiben und nicht aufzugeben weil wir es
gibt noch nicht nur ein standard
sozusagen was die dokumentation von ihm
von gm ist oder nicht geimpft angeht das
ist nicht ihr sehr theoretische sache
und bei dem aktuellen tempo auch wenn es
noch deutlich schneller gehen würde was
dessen konzerte wenn man dann besuchen
von macho oder von roger howard
carpendale das betrifft hier erstmal die
älteren und die risikogruppen wie kommt
daher am ende reichen minister gar keine
gedanken
von thomas spang meint also wenn es die
80-jährigen geimpft werden dann geht es
wohl eher mit den amigos konzerten los
gut die möchte natürlich auch auf die
nase
ja und ich was man auch noch nicht weiß
ist wie sich der virus weiter verhält
wie es durch verschiedene generationen
von mutation mit dem virus weiter geht
inwiefern man nicht weiter ansteckend
ist wenn man geimpft ist oder nicht und
das ist alles viel zu früh also ich
finde das dann blöd 89 schritte im
voraus ich den mund fusselig zu reden
wenn man eigentlich ganz andere probleme
wenn ich recht vor der haustür hat das
heißt ihr bei den vertrag hier seid da
ziemlich konform und sagt wir gehen auf
nummer sicher erst wenn es möglichst
gehen wir wieder auf tour und wenn es
dann halt die 33
die agentur ist nein also das sind zwei
verschiedene sachen ich spreche es davon
ob man geimpft oder nicht geimpft
diskutieren möchte zuschauer oder nichts
das ist das eine seltenheit spielen wenn
es wieder geht und das ist jetzt das hat
ist nicht so viel mit der diskussion zu
tun ob dem stand nicht geimpft
es ist so dass wir uns ja aktuell an
einer daten lösung namens luca
beteiligen von der wir glauben dass sie
viel früher und viel effektiver an mehr
oder weniger normal ist wieder
ermöglichen kann und dass behinderte
natürlich auch konzerte und sonst eben
auch das ganze andere öffentliche leben
weil das ist etwas was ich schon viel
sinnvoller halte und da bei luca ist es
auch so dass da die möglichkeiten ein
eventuell im status was mit einbauen
kann natürlich möglich aber es ist eine
frage ob das gewollt oder nicht
wenn ich menschen sagt wir haben in
ihrem buch wochen eben auch die
möglichkeit etwas zu hinterlegen ist das
nichts anderes als wenn man keine ahnung
beim fixen führerschein die app
hinterlegt aber wirkt trotzdem muss er
gewährleiste zahlen dass das
funktioniert und eine valide sache ist
das könnte jeder dar ein schreiben dass
er zwar nicht also etwas in einer app
möglich zu machen hat noch lange nicht
für den administrativen vorgängen zu tun
mit dem zusammenschluss an die
gesundheitsämter oder an die
bundesdruckerei das sind alles sachen
die wir mit luca bereits drauf haben und
wir helfen nicht ist auch keine
besondere nachricht es gibt verbitte mir
da ein bisschen schlecht ich hoffe das
legt sich gleich wieder aber genau das
ist das richtige stichwort ich habe mir
luca auch mal hier auf meinen tablet
geladener mit herz kurz angucken können
hier auf unseren bildschirmen im studio
das ganze sieht so aus wenn man mal
drüber schalten kurz auf den bildschirm
liebe regie 321 ist nicht drauf okay wir
haben vergessen das ganze zu koppeln
schade
gut ich behalte es manchmal so in die
kamera es ist relativ simpel immer noch
die app auf und dann ist das ein qr-code
was passiert dann nur die apps ein
ganzes system die app die wir gerade
gesehen haben das ist das frontend wenn
man so möchte mit diesem qr code der
sich minütlich ändern damit der
fälschungssicher ist kann man sich dann
quasi in restaurants einchecken oder in
museen man macht das gleiche was man
bisher in der dokumentationspflicht
machen musste spricht man hat da einen
zettel ausgefüllt nur dieses mal ist es
völlig anonym an die daten kommt leader
der betreiber also der
software betreiber run noch der
gastgeber spricht das restaurant der
konzertsaal noch die anderen oder auch
ich selber nicht es wird nur dann frei
geschaltet im infektionsfall auf
nachfrage vom gesundheitsamt damit ist
es auch bekommen ist auch den segen der
landesdatenschutzbehörde die menschen
haben in einigen bundesländern und ich
glaube dass auch gerade datenschutz das
vertrauen so zu sagen dass es eben eine
wirklich sichere sache ist es überhaupt
erst ermöglicht die
dokumentationspflicht zu digitalisieren
immer selbst die kommunisten
beispielsweise damit eingeläutet und man
kurz und in thüringen wird es ab nächste
woche öffentlich sind 23 gesamte
angebunden dort ist jena die modellstadt
wir haben aktuell gespräche mit dem
landesdatenschutz ender und dem
gesundheitsamt in baden württemberg dort
haben wir auch große pläne
beispielsweise wollen wir den
hochschwarzwald spielen auch als
tourismus location her sind gespräche in
hamburg mit st pauli und der reeperbahn
also es gibt ganz ganz viele geschichten
die mit luca einbinden wollen aber das
ganze greift erst dann wenn die
gesundheitsämter quasi wieder voll
funktional sind da wird immer gesagt das
geht erst wenn wir bei diesen berühmten
50 infektionen auf hunderttausend leute
in sieben tagen gelandet sind dann
können die überhaupt wieder arbeiten
oder würdest du sagen das ganze system
wird auch jetzt schon was bringen nein
das ist ja eh alles zu einer klaren noch
es ist zu noch müssen wir geringere
fallzahlen residenzen haben aber ich
denke dass die toleranzen erhöht werden
können ist es höher werden kann da
zukunft als 50 war dann kluger ist es
möglich infektionsketten chirurgischer
zu erkennen und gezielt zu reagieren
statt ich sag mal grobschlächtig mit der
doktor keule durch ganz deutschland zu
klappen
dass das eine es entlastet die
gesundheitsämter das ist eigentlich das
wesentliche bis jetzt ist die regelung
so wenn es überhaupt möglich wieder wäre
durch 1000 leuten einen
veranstaltungsraum wenn dann alten die
alle müssten titel ausstellen
dann wird einer krank dann haben sie
erstmal ein riesenhaufen 4000 steht da
muss er mitarbeiter oder dutzende von
mitarbeitern durch die listen gehen
anrufen zettel gelesen und dann stimmt
gleich gehilfen ich wieder eingetragen
wird alles quatsch funktioniert eben
foreman nicht wenn das alles
automatisiert ist daten sicher und sie
alle eingeschickt haben ist das noch ein
knopfdruck und sie können das mit den
leuten
als andere sachen machen lassen
christine konzepte gute andere
kooperationen und damit erhöhen wir die
möglichkeit haben wir das virus weiter
ein damit erhöhen wir die möglichkeiten
die gesundheit damit können wir sicher
auch mit höheren toleranz die linke denn
tieren rechnen aber da drängt sich mir
die frage auf warum das in der korona
app die er von der bundesregierung mit
nämlich ziemlich viel geld bezahlt wurde
nicht auch schon implementiert ist warum
muss da ein privatunternehmen oder die
privatinitiative kommen und sagen wir
machen das jetzt na ja die korona app
ist etwas anderes interessiert und sie
kommen aus einer anderen zeit
man hat jetzt ja auch viel gelernt und
dann ist da ja also ich bitte 4 haben
die pandemie aber nicht seit fünf jahren
sondern eben erst seit einem jahr und
deren zuge des anfangs der pandemie die
karawane verdacht worden und das sind
ganz andere sachen erlernt wurden von
uns allen das ist jetzt nicht so oder
als besonderes klar ist die karawane an
individueller rada der mir sagt liegen
haben ich und ein risiko aber es hat
sich herausgestellt dass individuelle
fragen gar nicht wichtig sind am
pandemisch gedacht muss man einen
größeren in clustern denken in kurorten
man kann hundert leute zum beispiel in
einen konzertsaal in eine ecke zu
grobschlächtig und 100 in die andere und
wenn dann einer infiziert haben sie
nicht 200 leute und so muss man das ein
bisschen zusammenfassen und das ist das
was du gemacht das sind zwei komplett
verschiedene dinge ich glaube das ist
ein guter mix aus der thora waren es dem
system luca günstigen selbsttests einer
entspricht nämlich im hintergrund und
üblichen hygienemassnahmen uns relativ
bald ein gutes mehr oder weniger
normales leben verschaffen kann
kulturelles leben nicht volles rohr aber
so dass er damit durch die pandemie
kommen könnten vielleicht einmal
abschließend jetzt eine frage die sich
vielleicht auch manche stellen seit
dient da irgendjemand an der app und
kostet die war es für die leute die sie
benutzen
nein neben dem datenschutz ist es ganz
wichtig dass die benutzer und auch die
betreiber in restaurants und herren das
leben nicht bezahlt es gibt
einrichtungskosten meine
gesundheitsämtern die beide über den
fall der vom bund oder vom land oder von
der bundesdruckerei bezahlt je nachdem
was das ist und das ist eigentlich das
wir wollen das kulturelle leben und wir
haben mit der indischen angefangen mit
den letzten jahres
august als sie gemerkt haben dass man
sowas braucht und haben festgestellt wir
sind die einzige lösung in ganz europa
ich weiß dass in ghana so was ähnliches
gibt in südkorea
das ist natürlich ganz andere politische
umstände und es sind daher haben wir ja
also wir haben zehn deutschen rap
erfolgt und jetzt ist luca systeme
aufrücken
er hat auch nicht warum wir das zum
ersten mal als wundert mich selbst aber
ich denke wir sind vielleicht weil wir
mit breitem kreuz gleich gesagt haben
wir müssen eine gesundheitsämter an und
nicht erst mal irgendwie eine erfassung
sap die check in check out
digitalisieren dass das kann ja jene das
system muss die man muss die
gesundheitsämter entlassen aber trotzdem
die frage darf warum ist da eine private
initiative von zugegeben bekannten
menschen die das auch breit machen
können nötig warum ist die politik da
nicht selber drauf gekommen
ich finde nicht dass man jetzt
hinstellen einstellen sollte unsere
abend sollte die politik muss das alles
verschenken die politik ich sag mal so
auch nur menschen
wir haben ohnehin gäste ohne ende zu tun
es gibt immer wieder gute findige ideen
die gerade aus der privatwirtschaft wie
effizienten mutigen viel schneller
gemacht werden müssen
bei einem nach einem bundesdeutschen
starts produkte haben sie doch hitze
viele administrative abstimmungs
vorgänger bis man sich überhaupt
überhaupt einigt also es ist so es
brennt jetzt reißt den feuerlöscher von
der wand ich frag doch nicht wer es mit
dem feuerlöscher und der dort war die
zeit nicht reichen von der wand ich
löschte das feuer
und dann hinterher kann man überlegen
machte damit weitermachen das ist mal
ein wort ich danke dir das motto für
diese vorstellung der app und für deine
worte gesagt großen schwierigen
diskussion und wünschen schönen abend
auch danke ja also die frage ist die
aufhebung von ja diesen grundrechts
einschränkungen die wir haben treibt
viele branchen oben auch die concert
promotion natürlich dies besonders
betroffen aber auch friseure die
reisebranche im grenze sind es sehr sehr
viele eine sehr sehr große
wirtschaftszweig der sich eingeschränkt
sieht und die ganze frage ob das jetzt
richtig ist oder nicht
diesen menschen die eine impfung haben
diese rechte zurückzugeben
die hat sich heute der deutsche ethikrat
angeguckt bisher schon länger aber heute
die ergebnisse vorgestellt stefan resch
fast uns ganz kurz zusammen was dabei
herausgekommen ist
wird das der gelbe freibrief werden
könnte der cronos dkm impfausweis weil
die erlaubnis für das kino konzert oder
den urlaub sein
dazu hat sich heute der ethikrat
geäußert und sich eher zurückhaltend
gezeigt auch weil noch nicht klar sei ob
geimpfte andere anstecken können
eine vorherige individuelle rücknahme
von freiheitsbeschränkungen nur für
geimpfte person ließ sie sich allenfalls
dann rechtfertigen wenn wie gesagt
hinreichend gesichert wäre dass sie das
virus nicht mehr weiter verbreiten
können
dabei wären zudem fragen der
gerechtigkeit sowie der folgen für die
akzeptanz der impfstrategie zu
berücksichtigen trotzdem spaß nur mit
spritze das könnte kommen und der
impfausweis zur eintrittskarte werden
denn in der wirtschaft gilt
vertragsfreiheit wenn es nicht gerade um
die grundversorgung geht
und so könnte es an der tür zum klub
bald nicht mehr nur aufs äußere ankommen
sondern auch auf die inneren werte oder
eben nicht das ist die große frage
darüber was wir jetzt diskutieren mit
professor aline bicks vorsätzen des
deutschen ethikrats wir haben sie da
schon ganz kurz im o ton gehört und ich
grüße sie jetzt im studio in berlin
hallo hallo guten namen jetzt haben wir
ganz klar schon mal gesagt ihr aus von
von ihrer seite aus finden sie das nicht
in ordnung wenn menschen die geimpft
sind die grundrechte zurückbekommen wie
schwierig ist in dieser entscheidung im
gremium gefallen also wir haben das so
nicht genau formuliert weil uns
natürlich klar ist dass es sehr sehr
schwierig ist dass wir alle diese
freiheitseinschränkung die staatlichen
über die ich jetzt mal zunächst spreche
weiter aushalten wir haben gesagt diese
staatlichen einschränkungen
die sind ja auch dafür da dass wir uns
gegenseitig schützen
und da geht es eben dann auch darum ob
man als geimpfte person noch jemand
anderen anstecken kann
es wäre unverantwortlich so was
aufzuheben wenn dann die person durch
die gegend läuft und alle möglichen
anderen auch anstecken kann
und da ist im moment gibt es erste
indizien und erste hinweise aber da sind
wir einfach noch vor
achtbaren datenlage ein ordentliches
stück entfernt und wir gehen davon aus
dass wir das auch erst wissen wenn das
impfprogramm schon ordentlich wirkung
zeigt also wenn erkrankungsfälle schwere
verläufe krankenhausaufnahmen und so
weiter deutlich runtergehen weil wir ja
gerade diejenigen mit den höchsten
risiken bevorzugt impfen so dass ich
dann
dann müssen diese
freiheitsbeschränkungen sowieso
vorsichtig und schrittweise aber für
alle aufgehoben werden so dass sich dann
quasi die frage hoffentlich tatsächlich
auch erledigt hat das klingt das haben
will wenn ich also sagen darf ganz klar
unterschieden von den angeboten privater
anbieter das ist wirklich wichtig das
muss man auseinanderhalten möchte gleich
auch so kommen aber das klingt jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen so als ob sie
sagen wissen sorry wir wissen eigentlich
noch gar nicht genug um diese frage
schlussendlich beantworten zu können
warum haben sie diese versucht trotzdem
ja schon zu beantworten
wir haben das angelegt also da haben wir
wirklich darum gerungen
das ist auch einfach schwierig die einen
sagen ihr müsst ganz ganz ganz weit nach
vorne denken wir sagen oder gibt so
viele unterschiedliche szenarien und so
viele sachen an denen dann fragezeichen
wäre das wäre dann schon sehr sehr
spekulative ethik gibt es einen
fachbegriff und der ist nicht gerade
positiv und die anderen sagen sagt da
gar nichts zu ja wieso redet ihr denn
jetzt überhaupt schon drüber also da das
so ist man sozusagen die tui working
hard place wieder dritten sagen wir
haben uns entschieden jetzt mal eine
klare aussage zu machen
für jetzt und haben vorsichtig angelegt
wenn man sehr viel sicherer wüsste dass
menschen nicht ansteckend sind dass man
dann diese frage noch mal neu angucken
müsste es tatsächlich sein dass die
rückgabe bestimmter
freiheitsbeschränkungen sogar geboten
ist und dann müsste man dann eben aus
ethischer perspektive noch darauf achten
dass das nicht zu großen
ungerechtigkeiten führt dass das nicht
schlechte effekte auf die impf auf das
impfprogramm hat aber das müsste man
sich dann noch mal angucken
nach viel konjunktiv ich habe hier schon
mal eine relativ rasche frage an sie
dich trotzdem mal weitergebe zum thema
grundrechte denn darüber reden wir ja
die grundrechte sind zum größten teil
eingeschränkt worden und ein user auf
youtube möchte wissen was erdreistet
sich ein ethikrat die demokratischen
grundrechte der menschen in diesem land
als verhandelbar zu erachten da höre ich
eine gehörige portion verärgerung heraus
ja also ich finde das ganz wichtig erst
mal das haben wir auch sehr deutlich
gesagt
überall wird ja immer noch dieser
begriff leider privilegien oder ihnen
wie sowas verwendet oder sonderrecht
oder sonst irgendwas also da haben wir
sehr klar unterschieden
es geht um die rücknahme von
freiheitseinschränkung es geht um die
rückgabe von grundrechten das ist
absolut richtig
im bereich der staatlichen maßnahmen und
bei den angeboten von privaten geht es
um eine differenzierung nach impfstatus
die dann eben private anbieter beim
umsetzen sind also das ist mal eine ganz
wichtige unterscheidung und wir haben
uns ja nicht dazu geäußert dass man die
grundrechte jetzt allen wegnehmen
sondern wir haben gesagt die maßnahmen
die im moment umgesetzt werden die sind
deswegen verhältnismäßig weil wir sie
brauchen um die pandemie einzudämmen und
weil wir das gesundheitssystem für alle
erhalten wollen und und das ist eben der
punkt für diesen ganz spezifische für
diese ganz spezifische fragestellung
weil wir auch noch nicht wissen ob die
geimpften denen wir die grundrechte
wieder geben würden nicht andere weiter
anstecken können dann die pandemie
wieder voll anheizen wenn ich das mal so
flatz ich sagen darf also wer dreisten
uns da nicht irgendwie urteile über
grundrechte jetzt ja jetzt nein einfach
so zu fällen sondern wir arbeiten aus
was die voraussetzungen jeweils wären
und das ist tatsächlich unsere aufgabe
und das ist leider will ich fast sagen
ein bisschen differenzierter als das
viele gerne hätten und ich kann das
wahnsinnig gut verstehen wir sind alle
wirklich müde und niemand hat zusagen
lust auf den zustand in dem wir schon
alle
so lange sind es gibt aber auch stimmen
die quasi fordern dass wenn jetzt mehr
es möglich ist dass menschen geimpft
sind und dann sich vielleicht freier
bewegen könnten weil sie eventuell dann
auch nicht mehr ansteckend sind oder
andere menschen nicht mehr infizieren
können
dass es dann eine schnellere rückkehr
zur normalität gibt unter anderem der
philosophieprofessor microns gabriel den
haben wir interviewt je mehr kämpfte
sich wieder normal bewegen können also
teilnehmen können an einem freien
sozialen austausch unter menschen jedem
je mehr die es möglich ist durch eben
die verbreitung der impfung desto besser
geht es selbstverständlich insgesamt
unserem gemeinwesen das ja dringend eine
rückkehr zur normalität braucht ja was
entgegnen sie den kollegen genau wir
haben was wir haben anderes argument
verwendet aber das geht in eine ähnliche
richtung
wir haben ja um himmels willen nicht
gesagt man dürfe
sozusagen niemals lockern sondern wir
haben ganz klar gesagt es ist sehr sehr
wichtig sobald sich die situation
verbessert und sobald auch die
impfstrategie wirkung zeigt müssen die
freiheitsrechte für alle schritt für
schritt um sozusagen verantwortlich aber
sind dann müssen sie wieder hergestellt
werden
das ist nicht nur für unser gemeinwesen
wichtig sondern das ist natürlich auch
für uns als individuen sehr wichtig wir
haben nur gesagt da man eben noch nicht
weiß ob geimpfte nicht weiter ansteckend
sind und dann diese mühsam errungenen
fortschritt den wir jetzt sehen
im kampf gegen die pandemie zu sagen
konterkarieren würden können wir jetzt
nicht sagen jetzt heben wir für die
geimpften die freiheitsbeschränkungen
aber das ist doch also sie machen den
unterschiedlicher für zeit zwischen
politik und wirtschaft also die politik
gibt kann jetzt also diese jene
maßnahmen vorgeben und sagen okay wir
machen jetzt alle restaurants dicht und
vorher kann sich der wirtschaft
überhaupt gar nicht anders verhalten
also man kann jetzt nicht hin als
restaurantbetreibern kann sagen wenn ich
jetzt aber geimpft reinlassen da muss
natürlich über diese hygienemaßnahmen
hinweg setzen sondern die sind ja an die
vorgaben der politik gebunden
das heißt erst wenn alle restaurants
aufmachen könnte sich ein
restaurantbetreiber dazu entschließen
oder ein konzertveranstalter zu sagen
hier kommen nur geimpfte menschen rein
aber es wäre doch auch möglich dass
politik genau das initiativ entscheidet
und sagt okay wir haben jetzt ein info
angebot für ungefähr die hälfte der
bevölkerung wir müssen zur normalität
zurückkehren also erlassen genau diese
maßnahme restaurants dürfen aufmachen
wenn sie nur geimpfte reinlassen das
wäre doch möglich oder wenn wir ein
angebot für die hälfte der bevölkerung
haben dann haben wir einen starken
effekt auf die pandemie also dann dass
wir sehen das ja nicht erst wenn die
hälfte der bevölkerung geimpft ist
sondern das ist vielleicht fiel nicht so
klar wir reden hier ja über eine
bevorzugung bei der impfung von den
menschen die besonders gefährdet sind zu
erkranken schwer zu erkranken ins
krankenhaus zu müssen auf
intensivstationen zu müssen das wird
sich das sehen wir jetzt gerade
beispielsweise in israel wo sich jetzt
gerade der trend umgedreht hat das sehen
wir sehr deutlich dass das passieren
wird und das heißt wenn wir der hälfte
der bevölkerung bei den imf angebot
machen können müssten diese
beschränkungen längst aufgehoben sein
das ist dieses argument wir haben das
weil wir da redlich bleiben wollten
deswegen ja auch angelegt das habe ich
gerade schon gesagt wenn das nicht
passiert dass man sich das dann noch mal
anschauen müsste gut an schrauben der
materialfrage ich also nicht vergessen
sondern zehn prozent der bevölkerung so
führen sie dann noch mit gehen und sagen
okay dann muss man dann muss man das
auch ermöglichen dann muss man aufmachen
ich mag also solche zusagen zahlen
punkte auf die man mich festlegen will
nicht ganz so gerne wie beim aber es
wäre erst mal die voraussetzung dann
tatsächlich noch einmal zu prüfen ob
diese menschen dann nicht noch wieder
andere anstecken können erstens zweitens
muss man sich klammern das ist auch
etwas was wir relativ intensiv
diskutiert haben wenn das so ein kleiner
teil der bevölkerung ist und ja auch
besonders risikogruppen betrifft
also diejenigen die jetzt sagen
besonders gefährdet sind durch die
pandemie oder die sich selber für uns
alle besonderen risiken aussetzen dann
ist das eine herausfordernde situation
zu sagen ihr geht in systeme wo wir noch
nicht sicher wissen ob ihr nicht doch
wiederum dann andere gefährden könnte
und es da ihm ein schnitzel oder so wir
haben eine ausnahme formuliert beim in
einem anderen bereich dem mann aus
ethischer perspektive sehr sehr viel
besser rechtfertigen kann und das sind
tatsächlich weitgehend geschlossene
systeme also wo ich nicht mal abends
irgendwie hin marschiere und dann ist
eine kellnerin keine ahnung was jetzt
mit der ist die ist ja nicht in
irgendeiner bevorzugten impft gruppe
also die ist zu dem zeitpunkt sicher
noch nicht geimpft
solche dinge muss man dann ja auch schon
ein bisschen mit bedenken sondern wir
haben gesagt es gibt systeme wo
eventuell alle geimpft sein werden weil
das alles menschen sind die zu einer
risikogruppe gehören also dass sie
nachts völlig 18 80 jährige dürfen
zusammen kaffee trinken weil das sind
das sind die das sind die menschen und
auch diejenigen die sie versorgen in
einrichtungen beispielsweise
langzeitpflege hospiz und so weiter und
die sind auch ganz ganz erheblich mehr
belastet in ihrem ganz essentiellen
lebensvollzug als viele viele andere und
da haben wir gesagt da gibt es immer
noch sehr sehr gravierende
isolationsmaßnahmen und in einem solchen
geschlossenen system da könnte man auch
da wiederum mit augenmaß
diese drastischen isolationsmaßnahmen
vorsichtig zurück nehmen also aber dann
heute an wieder zusammen den kaffee
trinken oder das amigos konzert könnte
dann wieder stattfinden
wenn das amigos konzert nur von menschen
umgesetzt würde die alle weil sie zur
risikogruppe gehören tatsächlich auch
geimpft wurden
das ist natürlich einfach ein sehr sehr
hypothetische feier also und plus
konzerte können ja einfach im moment gar
nicht stattfinden
also das ist das problem das sind auch
die die bühnenarbeiter und und die
menschen die die bühne aufbauen und
alles sie müssten auch alle geimpft sein
und die kriegen die impfung ja erstmal
nicht okay sorry das ist ein bisschen
ärgern musste aber die frage brauchen
wir zu hause sind alle berechtigte
fragen aber das interessante ist
tatsächlich dass die bundeskanzlerin hat
ja im ard-interview vor kurzem genau für
diesen fall auch gesprochen das heißt
wir haben einen info angebot für jeden
aber es gibt trotzdem menschen die
verweigern sich jetzt ist ja immer noch
die frage ob tatsächlich alle mitmachen
und wenn wir dann nur eine weise nicht
im quote von 40 prozent haben aber jeder
könnte dann hat sie folgendes dazu
gesagt dann muss man vielleicht schon
solche unterschiede machen und sagen
okay wer das nicht möchte der kann
vielleicht auch bestimmte dinge nicht
machen
würden sie damit gegen freiburg also das
ist jetzt nämlich ein anderer bereich
gehe ich jedenfalls davon aus weil die
kanzlerin dass da gar nicht in wie
ausbuchstabiert aber ich gehe davon aus
dass es da jetzt eben um den bereich
geht von angeboten durch private und da
haben wir relativ klar formuliert da
herrscht vertragsfreiheit
also wenn in diesen bereichen wieder
verträge gemacht werden können
dann können die anbieter die mit
denjenigen machen mit denen sie wollen
da könnten sie das auch nur geimpften
anbieten es sei denn da gibt es eine
einschränkung das sind angebote die für
eine basale teilhabe am
gesellschaftlichen leben notwendig das
müssen sie kurz wer seine zelle habe das
wort ist heute schon sehr oft gefallen
in der pressekonferenz da haben viele
menschen glaube ich fragezeichen gehabt
also das sind so sachen der basar
daseinsvorsorge ich gebe mein
praktisches beispiel ich habe ein
busunternehmen das oder ich habe einfach
alles kann auch öffentlicher nahverkehr
seien
es gibt einen brust nur den einen bus
der aus dem dorf in die nächste stadt
fährt so was darf man dann nicht
einschränken und sagen das ist nur für
geimpfte aber der italiener um die ecke
wenn es noch 25 andere italiener gibt in
dem viertel der könnte das machen und
ich glaube ich kann ich einschätzen ob
es in dem interview darum ging aber das
ist tatsächlich etwas was sich dann die
anbieter überlegen werden und wenn ich
so in die branchen reinhören
dann hört man da sehr unterschiedliche
meinungen die ein oder ansichten die
einen sagen ja wir wollen das machen
oder ich kann mir das vorstellen andere
sagen auf gar keinen fall
und ich persönlich glaube also das ist
jedenfalls meine bei noch offene
erwartung dass wir eigentlich nur eine
relativ kurze phase haben in der das für
die anbieter irgendwie groß interessant
wäre sondern dass man da mit smarten
lösungen es murat ja gerade eine sehr
smarte lösung vorgestellt
also sozusagen digitalen tools die man
einsetzen kann schnelltest und so weiter
und eben der erwartung dass immer mehr
menschen geimpft sind wir haben
eine gute impfbereitschaft dass man dann
als gastgeber das sind ja viele branchen
die sozusagen gastgeber sind er nicht
sagen wird ich mache das jetzt nur für
die geimpften ich habe hier einen
kommentar da geht so ein bisschen in die
richtung grundrechte wieder und das ist
eine frage die sich besonders junge
menschen hier im stream stellen
bisher ist der jugend gegenüber freiheit
für geimpfte bei diesen geringen impft
tempo im tempo einzuführen oder auch
generell ich habe hier noch einen
anderen kommentar gehabt wie kann es
sein dass sich unverschuldet nur weil
ich 39 jahre und kerngesund die impfung
als letztes erhalte und bis dahin keine
konzerte restaurants oder reisen tätigen
oder besuchen darf also da gibt es ja
auch schon unverständnis gerade mein
mann ist jungmann ist im grunde nicht
besonders ein risikopatient man könnte
sein leben genießen dann könnte auch die
wirtschaft wieder ankurbeln ist aber bei
den impfungen ganz am schluss und kann
dann überhaupt also dann müssen wir noch
länger warten bis es überhaupt alles
wieder den gang in die gänge kommt ok
ich glaube dagegen ein paar sachen
bisschen durcheinander
also ich mag man müsste vielleicht erst
mal erklären was ich total
ich verstehe den frust darüber total
warum jüngere bei den impfungen später
drankommen
weil da gibt es einen grund für das ist
ja nicht irgendwie so vom himmel
gefallen sondern da gibt es einen rechts
ethischen rahmen der vorgibt dass
diejenigen die besonders gefährdet sind
die besondere risiken haben aus sich
selbst heraus
prioritär geimpft werden oder diejenigen
die sich für uns alle besonderen risiken
aussetzen im beruf das sind vor allem
menschen im gesundheitswesen aber auch
in anderen bereichen der sogenannten
daseinsvorsorge also polizisten aber
auch erzieherin lehrerinnen und lehrer
und so weiter und so fort da gibt es
eine ganze reihe von gruppen die
ständige impfkommission hat das
aufgeschlüsselt in einer impfempfehlung
die wird ständig überarbeitet und da
wird die evidenz sozusagen ein gepflegt
wenn es da neue erkenntnisse gibt
und das ist ich finde das immer ich bin
da auch nicht unter den prioritären
gruppen
das ist wirklich hart aber junge
menschen haben einfach im vergleich zu
diesen risikogruppen deutlich niedrigere
risiken schwer zu erkranken oder gar zu
versterben und so bedingt sich so
bedingt sich verzeihung dass diese
priorisierung bei der impfung ist das
bedingt natürlich dass jüngere menschen
wenn sie nicht irgendwelche
vorerkrankungen haben oder bestimmte
funktionen also eben krankenschwester
sind oder was auch immer
lange warten müssen verstehe ich total
den france das heißt aber selbst die die
werden jetzt nicht geimpft und deswegen
sind irgendwelche sagen rückgaben von
freiheitsbeschränkungen für geimpfte für
jüngere menschen nicht erheblich das ist
ja gerade der punkt das wäre nur so wenn
man in der umgekehrten reihenfolge
kämpfen würde das heißt für jüngere
menschen für sehr sehr viele menschen in
diesem land ist vor allem wichtig dass
das impfprogramm insgesamt möglichst
zügig möglichst schnell möglichst
effektiv weiter läuft damit die
belastung des gesundheitswesens
runtergeht damit die pandemie eingedämmt
wird weil wir alle hoffen wir wissen
noch nicht wie viel aber wir alle hoffen
natürlich dass diese so genannte
transmission also die übertragung eben
doch reduziert wird damit dann für junge
menschen die beschränkungen aufgehoben
werden noch lange bevor sie dran sind
bei der impfung also das ganze ist dann
ja aber auch dass das hört man in den
kommentaren so ein bisschen naja ich
finde ich neiddebatte sagen aber es
klingt schon so ein bisschen
unverständnis und so ein bisschen neid
mit auch darüber haben wir den
philosophieprofessor markus gabriel mal
nachgefragt hätte auch ein standpunkt zu
ich glaube wir sollten insgesamt
umstellen ja von dem verdacht dass es
hier um neid und missgunst privilegien
und asymmetrien geht menschen die jetzt
eben besonders gefährdet sind denen
sollten wir gönnen möglichst schnell
ihre freiheit zurück zu erlangen stadt
eine diskussion darüber zu führen
das was das ich 22-jährige neidisch
darauf sind dass ihre großmutter wieder
ins restaurant
ja also frau weg sollten wir vielleicht
einfach mehr gönnen
also das glaube ich ist grundsätzlich ja
eine gute haltung aber noch nach
wir wissen nicht ob dann die oma im
restaurant nicht wieder andere anstecken
würde also das physische ware kann man
gut immer weglässt und das argument so
zu sagen wir machen mal jetzt die
hypothese
das finde ich dann schon auch schwierig
also da muss man redlich bleiben und das
haben wir versucht deswegen haben wir
jetzt mal für jetzt pflöcke ein gehauen
und ethische orientierung formuliert und
das habe ich ja eben auch schon gesagt
offen gelassen wenn wir das sicher
wüssten müsste man sich das noch mal
angucken und wie gesagt was den bereich
der privaten anbieter anbelangt sowieso
sobald die wieder aufmachen können
können die das ja machen
also ich finde dass nämlich das muss ich
jetzt auch mal sagen gemein wenn man
jetzt uns sagen würde ihr könnt hat
allen nicht ja und ihr seid ja so
wahnsinnig hart darum geht es wirklich
nicht sondern wir haben versucht zu
untersuchen mit dem was man jetzt weiß
worauf man sich jetzt verlassen kann wie
man das so gestalten kann dass möglichst
viele und nicht nur bestimmte gruppen
möglichst viele möglichst guten weg
durch diese pandemie irgendwie gehen
können jedenfalls in bezug auf diesen
teilaspekt also um gottes willen wir das
jetzt nicht über den natürlich nicht mit
blick auf alles sondern auf diesen teil
als bis klingt nach ein bisschen
undankbare aufgabe ein bisschen
frustriert oder fühlen sie sich
unverstanden in dem was jetzt empfohlen
haben nein das ist keine undankbare
aufgabe das ist ein schwieriges thema
und das ist eine schwierige aufgabe das
ist bei ethischen fragen häufig so wir
bemühen uns das muss man auch noch dazu
sagen es immer einfacher im eigenen
recht wenn ich mich als medizin ethik
professorin in wohin stelle dann kann
ich sozusagen eine andere position auch
vortragen als wenn man gemeinsam im
gremium empfehlung erarbeitet die man
auch im konsens trägt wo also auch viele
unterschiedliche positionen am tisch
sitzen und man das gemeinsam zusammen
führen muss das sind sehr sehr intensive
debatten und das muss ich auch sagen das
habe ich inzwischen
einfach dadurch gelernt dass wir jetzt
ja schon mehrmals empfehlungen
formuliert haben mannschaft das nie dass
man alle oder auch nur sehr sehr viele
sozusagen zufrieden stellt und alle
sagen das total super was ihr da
erarbeitet hat sondern man kann immer
nur versuchen das so gut wie möglich und
so gerecht wie möglich zu formulieren
und zu empfehlen und möglichst viele
oder also man bemüht sich natürlich
darum alle aber bleiben wir beschreiben
möglichst viele interessen möglichst
viele gruppen möglichst viele aspekte
mit einzubeziehen um dann eben zu einem
ergebnis zu kommen bei dem man sagt dass
es jetzt belastbar und wir erwarten ja
keine jubelstürme oder sowas sondern wir
hoffen dass wir in die debatte ein paar
punkte einbringen können dass wir da ein
paar sinnvolle unterscheidungen
einbringen also wenn dieser begriff der
privilegien verschwindet wäre das schon
mal super wenn diese vermischung die
immer stattfindet zwischen also dass man
immer sozusagen vermischt
freiheitsbeschränkungen staatliche
freiheitsbeschränkungen und die angebote
die private anbieter machen das sind
einfach doch recht unterschiedliche
konstellationen wenn uns das gelingt da
ein bisschen differenzierungen
reinzubringen
dann bin ich schon sehr zufrieden ich
lese hier bei unserem schätze bisschen
frustriert zum beispiel schreibt hey
wenn sich momentan nur hypothesen zur
beantwortung anbieten könnte immer gern
auf meinem rechner kurz schalten hier
ich markiere das mal dann hätte man das
ganze einfach aussetzen sollen dass es
eine klare datenlage gibt's also
trotzdem habe ja schon darüber
gesprochen warum trotzdem das jetzt
beantwortet werden sollte es ist einfach
eine schwierige zeit und da muss man
über sachen reden auch vielleicht früher
reden und hier die erinnerung von grüner
brink es gibt ja schon eine studie bei
astrazeneca dass es wahrscheinlich nicht
ansteckend ist oder zumindest dass es
diese sogenannte sterile immunität gibt
also dass nur das zu 67 prozent
die menschen nicht mehr andere menschen
anstecken und das könnte dann auch bei
anderen impfstoffen geltend das hörte
dann zumindest eine ja eine schleife
eine wendeschleife aus ihrer gleichung
herausnehmen frau box und dann wenn wir
schon schritt weiter für
heute sage ich aber erstmal vielen dank
dass sie sich noch die zeit genommen
haben nach diesem langen tag und diesen
schwierigen diskussionen mit uns darüber
zu reden und schönen gruß nach berlin
ziehen gerne dankeschön nun auch auf
vielen dank fürs zu sehen fürs
mitdiskutieren für eure meinungen ich
kann den frust natürlich verstehen wir
alle können den verstehen ich glaube
viele menschen sind kroner müde haben
wir auch tatsächlich heute auf instagram
noch was darüber gemacht könnt ihr mal
reingucken woran das liegt außerdem
möchte ich euch empfehlen
das video von meiner kollegin christiane
hübner von inside politics unserer
politik reihe aus dem hauptstadtstudio
berlin da hat sie diese ganze diskussion
um die frage ob freiheitsrechte die
impfen zurückgegeben werden können
nochmal aufgedröselt den zwölf minuten
kompakt könnt ihr auch gerne teilen
genau wie diesen stream unsere abo da
lassen und leichter lassen alles was man
so machen kann in diesem internet aber
erstmal ersten sack zu und sagt bis zum
nächsten mal
und tschüss